alguna vez intentaron pensar en un color
que no conoce
los invito a hacerlo ahora
cerremos nuestros ojos e intentemos
pensar en un color que no conocemos
este que estás pensando es el verde ese
ya lo conocemos es el naranja a este lo
llamamos amarillos es el violeta el rojo
pudieran hacerlo
seguramente no los invito a que abran
los ojos ahora
pensemos ahora en una ciudad la que
ustedes quieran de cualquier parte del
mundo
ver los grandes edificios
las autopistas atravesando la
en los grandes parques las luces led las
bicisendas
ven la fecha de chapa
las clases de tierra
las zanjas a cielo abierto
ven los cientos de cables
atravesados de manera precaria que no
nos permiten ver el cielo
seguramente no
cuando yo era chica y alguna novela o
alguna película siempre me preguntaba
por qué mi realidad no la veía reflejada
en esos ámbitos el primer beso nunca era
en un pasillo no había mi vecina con su
garrafa al hombro o alguien saliendo del
barrio con bolsitas en los pies para
embarrarse
mucho menos veía a los pibes buscando
tesoros en la basura cartón cobre
y cuando fui creciendo me basta
exactamente lo mismo
cuando empezó a estudiar ciencia
política y después de la mano de federer
pese a interiorizarme en el diseño de
las ciudades inteligentes y sostenibles
conocí el concepto de ciudad sus
indicadores sus metas
participé en diseños estratégicos
conocí ciudades modelos su desarrollo su
infraestructura
pero nunca encontré como una
problemática la garrafa al hombro las
bolsitas en los pies o el olor que nos
inunda en verano
no encontré planificación alguna para
transformar lo cotidiano de nuestra
realidad
y después pude acceder a otros datos que
me informaban que hay más de 4 millones
de personas viviendo en nuestro país en
barrios populares y el 90% lo hace en un
entorno urbano
en ese momento me di cuenta de algo
nadie nadie pero nadie
busca una solución a un problema que no
conocen que existe
cuando se piensa en un sistema integrado
de transporte se piensa cómo transitar
nuestros pasillos cuando se piensa en la
transformación digital que son la
solución se le da a nuestros pies que se
quedan sin conectividad
cuando pensamos en aumentar la
eficiencia energética
pensamos primero en garantizar el acceso
a la energía eléctrica
no se piensan estrategias para las
ciudades por un lado y otras para
nuestros barrios
los objetivos del desarrollo sostenible
nos plantean grandes desafíos para que
un futuro sostenible para todos sea
posible pero no vamos a lograr ninguna
acción por el clima mientras sigamos
construyendo sobre nuestros espacios
verdes o talando los pocos árboles que
nos quedan pero tampoco lo vamos a
lograr
mientras la contaminación en nuestros
barrios aumenta no estábamos caminando
hacia un sistema integrado de transporte
que sea sostenible accesible seguro y
resiliente mientras siga siendo tan
difícil transitar nuestras ciudades y
casi imposible hacerlo en nuestros
barrios
nosotros también somos la ciudad la
habitamos la construimos la transitamos
estamos en ellos
los son nuestros cables colgando
nuestras bolsitas los pies nuestras
zanjas a cielo abierto nuestra identidad
nuestra cultura
incluso
nuestro barro en los pies
yo soy lucía mamá tengo 32 años nací me
críe y sigo viviendo en barrio obrero un
barrio popular de san isidro del
conurbano norte
para mí este barrio es más que especial
sus propias calles se te hace en familia
y es muy chicos tuvimos que aprender a
imaginar los colores que no sabíamos que
existían no nos quedó otra
y lo digo así en plural porque no lo
hicimos solo lo hicimos en comunidad en
conjunto
lo hicimos cuando se nos fue leo y
tuvimos que organizando para despedirlo
lo hicimos cuando nos tuvimos que
organizar para tener agua
para organizar el día de la niñez o
simplemente bancar en las malas y
compartir las buenas
y yo la realidad que puedo ser solamente
una vía un barrio que pude acceder a
otras herramientas que busco conocer
otros colores
pero no me quedo solo con eso
porque mis vivencias y esta experiencia
mis necesidades y mis falencias me
dieron una perspectiva
pero no me quedo solo con eso
porque hay cosas
que siguen pasando a mí me duelen mucho
más porque sé que otras personas las
siguen sufriendo
y que el tiempo no transformó
absolutamente nada
11 años tenía
11 años tenía cuando abrí la canilla y
me enteré que también podría salir agua
caliente
para mí eso fue descubrir un nuevo color
se imaginan ustedes cuántas cosas
normalizamos y en nuestros barrios nos
faltan
y como les decía elegir o quedarme solo
con eso sino que elegí transformar mi
barrio en mi espacio mi entorno
junto con mis vecinos creamos una huerta
comunitaria
porque sabemos que es necesario que
nuestro barrio también se alimenten de
manera más saludable
creamos espacios públicos itinerante con
acceso al arte a la cultura al deporte
al ocio porque también queremos brindar
un acceso universal a zonas verdes y
espacios públicos seguros e inclusivos
ahora estamos trabajando en un proyecto
de paneles solares porque en el barrio a
veces en invierno nos quedamos sin luz
pero sobre todo porque también creemos
que una eficiencia energética con
energías más limpias es posible y su
acceso tiene que ser universal
es por eso
a quienes habitamos los barrios
populares nos invitó a que seamos
nosotros quienes pensemos esa ciudad
donde para tomar un bondi no tengamos
que salir a la esquina donde dejemos de
normalizar
el olor que nos inunda en verano o
dejemos de naturalizar que en invierno
por más eficiencia energética que
intentemos hacer
la luz se va igual
mi hermano alguna vez que me llegó el
desánimo me trajo una frase de acro
que hice los pocos medios nos volvieron
exactos yo estoy convencida eso es así
porque quienes vivimos en los barrios
todo el tiempo buscamos transformar
nuestra realidad y lo hacemos en cosas
tan básicas y cotidianas como poner un
ladrillo en el piso para no embarrar nos
cuando llueve pero con nosotros solos no
alcanza
no somos ni quienes tenemos los recursos
ni mucho menos quienes tomamos todas las
decisiones
es necesario que pensemos las ciudades
sostenibles
incluyendo la realidad de nuestros
barrios y que su tratamiento sea de
manera integral
y no lo necesitamos solamente para
quienes vivimos en los barrios lo
necesitamos para todos para la ciudad
y todo lo que lo habitamos
busquemos una solución a este problema
que si existe y que ahora sí vemos
y pensemos de esa ciudad
pensemos la comunidad donde estemos
todos las organizaciones la sociedad
civil el sector privado los gobiernos y
haga pueblo en comunidad porque
seguramente si no lo hacemos así nos
quedan un montón de colores sin poder
conocer pero sobre todo porque en mi
barrio obrero soy su gente y su historia
así me lo demostró toda mi vida
pensemos esa ciudad hagamos real salir
salgamos del discurso y hagamos real que
los asentamientos humanos y las ciudades
sean seguros resilientes inclusivos y
sostenibles lo podemos hacer ahora lo
tenemos que hacer ahora
pensemos esa ciudad
y ahora que ya tenemos los ojos bien
bien abiertos ustedes se pusieron a
pensar cuántos colores hay que no
conocemos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]